400 years ago
brave settlers landed in a new world
they cleared dense forests survived
unforgiving winters
and befriended their native american
counterparts all in the service
of founding the very town in which
you're standing
right now
i'm nathan rutherford and it is my
distinct honor to introduce you to some
of those men and women
but before i do that does anyone
have to go potty all right
i'm gonna hold you to that come on
now our journey begins with this man
lawrence rutherford founder of this town
and my patriarchal ancestor
fun fact i'm actually the last
rutherford to live here in rutherford
falls
anyone see the resemblance i definitely
see it
it's in the jaw shoulders through the
chest and
probably some other places okay thank
you
in 1932 then governor of new york state
franklin d roosevelt
visited rutherford falls and he enjoyed
a hot slice of
lucy rutherford's rhubarb pie right here
in this chair i still get chills
thinking about it
and then he cried i banish you all to
hell possums
and thus ended the possum infestation of
1747
and lawrence rutherford gazed upon the
majestic valley
and thus declared this is where we
belong
and so in 1638 he brokered a uniquely
fair and honest deal
with our neighbors the minishanka thus
establishing
our town now the terms of the deal were
laid out in this
document one of those terms was to honor
the exact location
the deal was made which is why a century
later both parties came together
and erected a statue of old lawrence
affectionately known today
as big larry question
did they make a statue of andy
minashanka
great question and bronze was very
expensive at the time
so they really only had a budget for the
one
so but if you're interested in minnesota
history then i strongly encourage you to
visit their cultural center
which is run by my good friend regan
put that back please thank you okay none
another see these exhibits
they all need to remain historically
accurate it's very precise
what is funny they're kissing in what
world is vandalism funny no it's it's
fine
why don't we visit avery p rutherford's
frame room
he believed that the frame not the
painting deserve center stage
come on
you